[Applauso]
[Musica]
primo novembre 1998 ti dice niente
siete sicuri gran premio del giappone
schumacher si ritira mika hakkinen con
la mclaren vince gara e mondiale
immagino sia un ricordo triste per i
ferraristi ma non per me lo so modena
uguale ferrari ma quel giorno quella
macchina quella freccia d'argento quel
motore mi hanno cambiato la vita
quel giorno ho capito che da grande
avrei voluto fare le macchine e adesso
sta per diventare ingegnere del veicolo
all'epoca i motori motori rombanti
motori a combustione erano il cuore
pulsante dell'auto e io me ne innamorai
avevano il suono di quella musica che
non stanca mai avevano il suono della
mia musica preferita
adesso le cose sono un po diverse il
futuro è elettrico e la genialità
visionaria di enel mask ce lo conferma
ogni giorno poi avete mai pensato di
comprare un'auto elettrica
non so ci sono delle perplessità
riguardo al fatto che nonostante
l'accelerazione di queste vetture sia
bruciante 0 100 in 3 4 secondi la
ricarica delle batterie parliamo di
batteria anche da 100 kilowatt
l'equivalente di 2 mila batterie da
smartphone avviene ancora rallenti però
solitamente quello che ci spinge verso
questa idea era volontà di essere un po
più vicini all'ambiente un po più amici
dell'ambiente un po più eco friendly ma
non basta
non basta avere un'auto elettrica per
rendere il mondo un luogo più pulito non
pasta l'acquisto in sé per sfruttare
appieno le potenzialità di questa di
questa tecnologia
oggi nel mondo ci sono 1.2 miliardi di
veicoli
nel 2050 avremo circa 5 miliardi di
vetture circolanti dovrà dunque cambiare
per forza di cose molti muoversi e di
viaggiare anche fra non passare tutta la
vita a cercare parcheggio ma perché
l'auto elettrica da sola non basta
l'auto elettrica secondo uno studio
pubblicato nel 2018 dal parlamento
europeo produce durante il suo ciclo di
vita completo che comprende anche la
produzione dell'energia elettrica per la
ricarica e lo smaltimento delle batterie
a fine vita
un quantitativo di emissioni inquinanti
di co2 inferiore del solo 20 per cento
rispetto ad una equivalente auto diesel
questa differenza potrebbe aumentare
fortemente fino ad arrivare alle
teoriche emissioni zero se l'energia
elettrica per la ricarica venisse
prodotta sfruttando l'energia
rinnovabile sfruttando dunque il sole
l'acqua e il vento vedete quindi non
basta avere un'auto elettrica per
inquinare di meno ma servirebbero tutta
una serie di investimenti mirati per
fare in modo che avvenga realmente una
rivoluzione energetica ma l'auto
elettrica da sola non basta soprattutto
perché essa implica chiaramente una
rivoluzione tecnologica ben lontana
dall'essere completa ma necessita in
particolar modo di una rivoluzione di
cui noi non siamo ancora consapevoli
una rivoluzione culturale
l'elettrico ha il potere di cambiare il
modo di viaggiare e cambiare l'idea è la
concezione del viaggio ma anche qui non
basta semplicemente avere un'auto
elettrica per viaggiare in maniera
differente serve un cambio di mentalità
anche da parte nostra
immaginiamo ad esempio di partire per un
viaggio per andare in vacanza con la
nostra famiglia
bene quindi siamo propensi a fare un
viaggio di piacere senza la fretta
l'ansia tipica delle giornate di lavoro
di lavoro comunque cerchiamo di arrivare
a destinazione il prima possibile
non siamo pronti mentalmente
culturalmente ad affrontare un viaggio a
tappe soprattutto forzate per ricaricare
l'auto poi c'è anche da dire
effettivamente che spesso i punti di
ricarica
disposti luoghi poco appetibili per una
pausa di qualche ora prendiamo gli
autogrill ad esempio dove spesso sono
dislocate le colonnine di ricarica
una volta quando il viaggio ha concepito
come slow erano visti come dei veri e
propri ristoranti dove tutta la famiglia
si fermava e si e faceva un pranzo come
fosse la domenica dalla nonna con una
digestione ancora più slot del viaggio
oggi invece sono dei luoghi dove ci si
ferma per una pausa molto veloce ed
effettivamente pensare di stare tre ore
in un piazzale in mezzo all'autostrada
mentre la nostra auto si ricarica non è
il massimo ma immaginiamo che questi
punti di ricarica siano disposti fuori
dalle autostrade i luoghi belli luoghi
che meritano di essere visitati un
piccolo borgo immerso nelle colline
toscane o una città d'arte potrebbero
offrire delle enormi opportunità di
intrattenimento
anzi potrebbero essere proprio queste
attività culturali il criterio per la
scelta delle tappe intermedie di un
viaggio che non avrebbe dunque il solo
scopo di portarci a destinazione ma di
farci conoscere tutto ciò che
attraversiamo per giungere alla meta
dunque il passaggio e la sosta delle
auto elettriche potrebbe diventare per i
comuni una vera e propria opportunità
perché se un comune entrasse nella mappa
di ricarica diventerebbe a sua volta una
meta appetibile una meta turistica di
quel turismo eco sostenibile di cui si
parla molto il nostro pianeta realmente
bisogno dunque un punto di ricarica
potrebbe attrarre esattamente come
attrarre un museo un parco archeologico
o un qualsiasi una qualsiasi attività
culturale e dunque questa è una enorme
opportunità
vedete la questione è tutt'altro che
esclusivamente tecnica l'aspetto
culturale entra pieno titolo in questa
rivoluzione ma servono dei segnali di
consapevolezza e un segnale forte che
mostrerebbe esattamente quella che è la
duplice natura di questa rivoluzione
potrebbe essere la richiesta delle
colonnine di ricarica nei comuni
oggi questa richiesta viene solitamente
avanzata dagli assessorati alla mobilità
all ambiente ma potrebbe essere avanzata
proprio dagli assessorati alla cultura
gli assessorati alla cultura che
andrebbero a gestire due aspetti
estremamente legati l'attività culturale
e l'attrazione verso di essa il punto di
ricarica quando mi innamorai dei motori
dei motori rombanti dei motori a
combustione non è che non volesse essere
co friendly ci mancherebbe non mi ponevo
nemmeno il problema ma poi studiando e
crescendo ho capito che il mondo cambia
troppo velocemente da un punto di vista
tecnico è troppo lentamente da un punto
di vista culturale
ho capito che una rivoluzione
tecnologica senza una consapevolezza
culturale non basta
ho capito che qualora questo mondo mi
chiedesse di rinunciare alla mia musica
preferita il rombo del motore del quale
tutti noi siamo innamorati lo farebbe
per diventare un mondo migliore
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]